within our market economy we think of us
as having the ability to vote through
our dollars so it's one dollar one vote
but we've seen inequality in this
country increased so dramatically
recently that we are in some sense
hearing some voices much more loudly
than others if you look at the percent
of income that is going to the top one
percent of our population in the last 20
years it's doubled from 10 percent to 20
percent if you look at the pay of CEOs
compared to the pay of the average
production worker it went from being
something like twenty four times the pay
of an average production worker to being
closer to two hundred times in many ways
the voice of our working-class Americans
is no longer be is no longer being heard
at the same level because they don't
have as much control within that economy
so they're looking to what we can think
of as another economy a separate place
to hear their voice which is our ballot
economy and we've always believed that
our ballot economy represents one person
one vote
of course we're seeing changes in that
too we have come to understand very
clearly the effects of gerrymandering
over the last several years we have seen
in this last election the impact of the
electoral college and what that does to
the voice of the majority and we also
understand that when you have two
senators from the state like Wyoming or
from Vermont and two senators from
California that in fact we don't really
have one man one vote but we have enough
equality within that system that we
actually will force to listen to the
voices of people who have felt
disenfranchised in our market economy so
what are these policies that have caused
people to react in this way well we can
think of just a few of them if we think
about finance immigration trade very
often we have been told by the
establishment that immigration
represents a win-win for America the
trade represents a win-win for America
well let's go a little deeper into that
is that really true as economists when
we think about welfare we're very
careful to think about ourselves as
technocrats so we don't want to decide
for a society what distribution within a
society should look like and so we have
this notion of welfare called Pareto
welfare and we think of something as a
Pareto improvement if you can make at
least one person better off by making
nobody worse off as you can imagine this
is somewhat difficult within a policy
context it's very hard to find a way to
have any policies that make that have no
negative impacts on anyone but can make
some people that are off so we found a
refinement to that something we call
Kaldor Hicks we look at the net benefit
versus the net cost and if the idea is
that we can have a net benefit and we
can redistribute it amongst the losers
so we we take whatever benefit we have
to the society as a whole and we'd
redistribute so that overall people are
better off well then we have a Kaldor
hicks improvement and we think of that
as a welfare improvement let's look at
what is going on in the situation of
trade so we know with trades there are
winners and there are losers we also
know that by the principle of
comparative advantage that we're going
to actually have an efficiency gain so
you're going to have some transfer where
American consumers do better off because
we have access to goods at better prices
and American producers maybe lose some
of their resources because they can't
sell as much to our economy and they
have to face a more competitive economy
and then we know that we also have this
competitive gain and if you add up the
benefit and the cost you find that in
fact we have an overall benefit what we
often cure when we hear about trade is
that it's a win-win situation and what
we're really referring to is the fact
that we have a Kaldor hicks improvement
except we use economist and
stand that there's one more piece to
that which is that in order for everyone
to be better off we really need to find
a way to redistribute that income away
from the winners and towards the losers
so that they're compensated for their
loss similarly if we look at immigration
there are winners and losers there are
at least three things that happen when
we increase immigration in this country
wages go down as the supply for labor
goes up and as a result of that there is
some transfer from domestic workers to
foreign workers there's some transfer
from domestic workers to domestic
capital because the cost of waiter wages
has just gone down there is also an
efficiency gain so GDP does indeed go up
as we increase immigration and it goes
up by more than just the benefits to
foreign workers and domestic capital
however the incidence of the loss has
just fallen on domestic workers and
unless we can actually carry out the
next piece of that which is the
redistribution everyone is not winning
from this there are designated winners
and designated losers so as economists
we understand that there is a trade-off
between efficiency and equality and we
understand that any kind of redistribute
of policies that we undertake is going
to have some cost in terms of efficiency
which is the amount of welfare that we
can actually provide to a society as a
whole and achieving maximum efficiency
has very much to do with understanding
what people's choices are and allowing
them to maximize their choices given
whatever the constraint set is anytime
you have a tax or any kind of
redistributed policy we're changing the
incentive structure by changing the
price system and so we're introducing a
distortion which is always going to have
some kind of efficiency effect we're
always in this position of needing to
decide how much efficiency and how much
overall welfare do we want to give up so
that we can actually have a more
whole society and this is the piece that
ends up being more of a political choice
than a technical choice and it's also
the piece that's very hard to get people
to push through politically except that
what we're now seeing in terms of this
populist backlash is that people are
saying things have shifted maybe too
much to one side maybe we need to
rethink where we are in terms of this
trade-off and in fact the establishment
and the educated elite understands very
well what feels wrong and they
understand that there is a piece of this
that we haven't been fully honest about
it may not be a zero-sum game but it's
also another win win and in order to
understand the message that we're
getting from Rust Belt America we need
to understand what the real implications
of these policies have been for them
[Music]
you